hey everyone it's Mike from water flows
and I'm grating this video on trading on
very short time base charts and what do
I mean by a very short time based
charting almost traders most people are
new to trading you know they come in
they start looking at a one minute chart
a 5 minute chart a 15 minute charts they
don't know what sort of chart to look at
and oftentimes when they start getting
into a trade and it's going wrong say
they're looking at a 5 minute chart then
the start saying breaking it down say oh
you know I'm in this trade I got to
start looking at a one minute chart and
micromanaging it now what I'm gonna be
talking about is choosing a short time
base for your actually trading you know
a big believer I'm not one of these
people that likes to say well yeah I
look at a 30 minute chart than a 5
minute chart in a 1-minute chart I break
it down no I trade the chart that's in
front of me I've always done that and
what I'll be talking about is trading on
a short term chart like a you know sub
one-minute chart so before I begin brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation of a higher sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
that's my decision
futures trading contain substantial risk
and is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for trading annoying
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading patch for it's
not necessary indicative of future
results alright so that's out of the way
let's take a look what do I mean by a
short term charts you know short short
timeframe charts you know if a friend of
mine runs a trading room and he actually
has a he has a five second chart up in
there and you know for me I find that
too short and yeah but really five
seconds is not I mean what's five
seconds it's one one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand four one
thousand five one thousand you know if
you're a pure scalper right there was on
the floor and the Board of Trade thing
that's called the Alpha traders group I
mean they would get in a position and
they're just hold it for seconds like
one one thousand two one thousand three
one thousand and then they're out you
know scratched the trade and move on to
the next trade and in trading on a
shorter term timeframe you
you're not gonna be looking to hold a
position for an hour right you're gonna
say you're on a 15 second chart like
this is a Nasdaq 15 second chart you
know if you're trading it and you're
still in a position after you know five
minutes in the position better be going
in your favor big time or otherwise you
should be out you know I should be in
and out pretty quick I mean that's why
you're trading a shorter term timeframe
you know sometimes you know people they
get caught up in in trades you know like
I said you know people like to look at
5-minute charts but then as soon as they
get into a trade they're they're
managing every single tick lycoming you
know they're living and dying every time
it goes up a tick goes down a tick you
know they're they're they're they're
kind of themselves but you're on a
5-minute chart you gotta give it time
give the trade time to grow and I said
if you're not doing that then you know
you should be on a shorter timeframe
chart you know it's like say you're
trading on a on a five-minute sorry a
one-minute chart but you find yourself
getting out of trades within 1530
seconds well stop looking at one-minute
chart look at a shorter timeframe chart
than if that's how you're gonna be
managing the trade I mean you kind of
give a trade some time to work out so
the thing is with you know shorter
timeframe charts you know me I'm big on
order flow and profiles and such but
really what what I use is is I look at
order flow I mean you know really I mean
that that's how I've always looked at
the markets and you know I've got my
tools that I use on the order flows
trader to spot things and really what
I'm looking for is I said if I'm trading
on a 15 second chart I'm looking for the
market to make its move over the next
two or three bars if it's not making its
move over the next two or three bars
there's no reason to be in that trade so
again you know I keep talking I've been
creating odd into these videos on this
prominent point of control feature in
the order flow is trader but you can see
here I know there's resistance here
right if I'm getting in in the next bar
I'm looking for it to sell off over the
next few bars okay which it does here
right even it's 15 seconds I here's the
30 seconds 45 seconds one minute okay so
you know within a minute you've sold off
from you know the 7576 area down into
the 78
one minute now again you know it's
another example of a tray this is this
morning in the mini Dow like here okay
so if I'm getting short on this bar I
saw after I got my prominent point of
control I know there's resistance up
here if I'm getting short here the
market just goes against me immediately
I'm out you know you don't stay in that
trade they can wanna give it some time
to to work out one you got to realize
when the trade is wrong and get out and
two if it's suppose it didn't stop me
out here and it's just going sideways
here here here for the next one minute
you know I wouldn't be interested in
that trade anymore you know this is nice
another one you know here's a buy okay
support primary port of control for
support next bar you know it spikes down
it opens up sells off rallies back up
you know this is a 15 second bar you can
see how the Nasdaq moves gives you an
idea you know from a range of 82 up to
85 okay settles you know 15 seconds
later it's still unchanged okay you know
no need to panic right now I'm not
stopped out and it's not going in my
favor and it's just hanging around
unchanged but then the next bar is where
you get your pop up you know from the 85
all the way up to 90 then just sort of
hangs around hangs around starts coming
off again so you know like on this trade
maybe you could have got something out
of it you know a few points this one
just sort of going sideways you know
it's this half-hearted half-hearted
starts coming down here you know hey
after three bars it's not going where
you expect it to go you get out you cut
your loss look for the next trade don't
say well now I'm gonna start
handicapping okay because look at this I
had a trade and you know it lost me some
money lost me a couple couple points
here you know so traders losing traders
tend to do is they tend to say well you
know what I had one trade you know this
trade I think get as much out of it as I
wanted to then this next trade you know
I took a loss of two points you know I
sit off the next one until you know
until they start stringing together
winners
well by the time we start stringing
together winners you've missed them you
know you look for the next trade here
you go next trade boom I'm gonna point
of control okay you know it's a time
duration chart so you know you get
little things they put a clock up there
so you know you know it counts down each
bark
our timers you get them for free just
got searched the internet and you know
and go from there so you know you know
at 14 seconds you got to be ready gotta
be queued up to the trade you know it's
funny because you know nowadays there's
all these execution algos right time
slicers or things like that V web you
know in the old days you know on the
trading desks what we do and have these
algos you know this is back in the the
early 2000s before computer technology
really advanced in as far as trading
order management systems you know way
would do time slicers we'd have a
freaking timer like those little egg
timers sitting on our desk you know say
okay well yeah you know I've got I got a
buy X amount of snps spread out over the
course of the day because you know
you're trying to get an average price
and you just you know you'd break it up
and into you know whatever 30 minute you
don't depend how big your order was you
break it up over the you know the the
trading day and and time slice it that
way and just use a timer you know
there's some funny stories there but I
won't get into it but you know you're
looking for the move to happen
immediately right here you know 70 to 80
to area so into 81 all the way back down
to somebody you know below 70 to 75 you
know its quick five points you know so
you know if you're sitting here saying
well you know I got a five point move
here but I only got a point or two out
of it then this one it lost you know
maybe maybe you know I'm not just sharp
as I shouldn't be well then you sit out
this trade because now son you're
handicapping yourself as a trader in the
sense self I'm saying when I say
handicapping what I mean is in terms of
you know when you know if it's the
gambling sense of handicapping not like
physical impairment you know where
you're gonna you know in handicapping in
horse racing right you get the Racing
Form you look over the past performances
everything and you can get you you go
from there that's what's called
handicapping and traders tend to do that
to themselves they tend to try to
analyze themselves and say well I'm
gonna wait for another winner or two to
come by and you know before I start
taking trades again rather than just
taking the trade when they appear you
know so that was a nice trade right
there you could got but you know if
you're sitting around well you know I
want to see some winners coming through
here
you know this one is debatable this one
probably woulda came down in here you
know I wouldn't take a net loss there
but yeah that's how you know how you can
approach looking at you know shorter
term timeframe charts again you know
where you gonna place your stop you know
here it's a 15-second chart
you got realized it's not as it's not a
range based chart so you know where the
next bar opens up you know he is
basically right around where you're
closing the previous bar so you know if
you close the bar down and it's here you
got a big area to go if you're gonna be
placing a stop up here but you're
opening you know right around your high
of the previous bar you know you might
have your stop a little higher you know
so maybe we didn't stop you out there so
I don't know you know if you find this
video helpful great you know if you
don't okay fine you know I mean you know
short-term training is not for everyone
there's a reason why I'm talking about
this short-term training is because and
working on some top secret I'll go but
it deals with a shorter term timeframe
charts and you know order flow is great
for that because you're trading in the
now you know that's where people get
lost in trading as they they like to
analyze you know things from distant
past you know there's a saying you know
I'm trading desk you know and when
someone would think they got some some
news story that's going to affect the
market you know they tell ya and then
people say you know two things
breaking news man lands on moon or
breaking news Queen Elizabeth is is dead
and what it is is just tells you that
you know you that's that's old news that
you're trading in the in based on past
stuff you know order flow really gives
you information about what you're
trading right now I know there's
resistance here okay I know that we sold
off started rally up hit a resistance
level ok we'll look for the market to
come off immediately you know come down
here we got a support level I'm looking
for the market to rally so hopefully you
found this video useful and you know I'm
trying to get more videos out on a
fairly regular basis now so thanks
everyone be sure to subscribe to the
YouTube channel if you haven't have a
great day bye bye